guys it's gonna be a fast-paced video
because huh we're gonna review a
fast-paced movie it's called hard hard
and horror and agree so hardcore that
Jerry's doing cocaine right now no no
jam it does it look good on you I am
allergic to many things for cocaine
Jerry
way better coke sober Jerry hardcore
Henry we've watched the trailer we
watched the IndieGoGo action scene
they're released
that's what was shown to us before this
movie was released I didn't even see the
IndieGoGo one whoa that's a spoiler and
I saw like the GoPro YouTube video from
like years ago and here's what most of
us were expecting just a two-hour POV
movie that is just non-stop action so
you're probably gonna get a headache and
you're probably gonna get into it as
well yeah you're like this looks awesome
I don't for like what minutes at most I
don't know if I'd want to do this we
watched the movie and it's a movie it's
not just action scenes it's a full
[ __ ] film it's got a whole story to
it that's one thing I'll say is even
when there was no action scenes I was
genuinely engaged in the story if
anything the story made the action
scenes that much better for you because
this movie has more sci-fi elements than
I think I was expecting I think you were
expecting and and that's the thing is
like it hooks you with like when it's
not being crazy action there's also this
like very odd you know sci-fi story
unfolding underneath so there are quiet
moments that are still thrilling because
they're disconcerting and it's all kind
of futuristic it's weird because it's
not exactly like overblown sci-fi but
it's definitely not subtle
you can tell early on this film is not
just an action film it's a science
fiction movie at the same time if you
were watching the trailer I'm wondering
like how the hell would I be interested
in this you can't even see the main
character don't want to give away how
they do it but know that everybody in
the movie you're like Henry is a pretty
cool [ __ ] dude whoa and that's what's
so cool about this is that this is
actually you know it's it has this this
gimmick you know that's all no way
during another baby what makes this
movie so cool is that I feel like the
gimmick is a bit more to me than just a
gimmick like this seems like a
worthwhile you know film experiment and
they really rose to the occasion and
made that four hour and 45 minutes of
first-person intensity work to the point
where halfway through I was like this is
cool I don't know if I'd ever watch it
again then like three quarters of the
way through I was like I love this like
this is incredible even action cinema
over the years like it clearly is
thinking about action it references a
lot of different times and places in
action it puts you at Ivor Z for a lot
of crazy experience in it it gives you
like serving likes tech on a technical
level it's not the most original story
like in terms of you know like how it
all plays out and everything it's not
exactly what I would say a cliche movie
if that makes any sense
because they're giving you stereotypes
like oh here's this action sequence that
you've kind of seen it like this action
sequence like here's the car chase
here's the fight with the group here's
the one-on-one finders the fight with
the big Russian dude or whatever when
those scenes are there you want them
there like they're all place at the
right moment all the action scenes are
not repetitive they're all different in
their own way well yeah the movie finds
a way to actually ramp up over time yeah
so like it starts out and and the
violent of the action is all kind of
small and actually kind of jarring and
disturbing cuz it feels real in there
lastic situations and then the movie
creates this weird you know space for
your head to be and because everything
looks realistic because it's from the
first-person point of view of a person
in as close and approximation as we're
used to seeing with these ridiculous
like over-the-top action scenes and that
gives it this like ridiculous sense of
humor yeah dome ISM the film it knows
it's silliness and at the same time
there are certain like moments or plot
beats that are stock action movie but
that didn't take away from it for me
because a like I feel like they matched
each one with like a really creative
thing about their universe but they also
I think used those trope moments as a
way of kind of poking at the action
movie formula like almost not saying
that it's like necessarily meta but
almost being meta about it like that
makes any sense
how's it looking at the camera thing
going good good man every actor you see
in the trailer is great you know like
Haley Bennett does a really good job
and the guy who played the villain in
the movie is great he's that albino do
you see in the trailer he is really he's
menacing but he has a lot of fun with
the role that could have been another
role that was done in a way where it's
like this is very typical well that's
the thing about all the performances
here is like every actor that like like
a Haley Bennett and everybody they got
they all played these stock or kind of
vague roles with you know little nuances
and you get the sense that they were
real character yeah like with very
minimal dialogue and very minimal
intimate moments they were able to you
know let the actors really play and make
these characters you know fun to watch
and sharlto copley is them he's he is so
you walk away from this really going
well my favorite scenes the action
scenes or all the scenes were Sharlto
Kobe yeah like we're not gonna spoil
what it is but they do something really
cool with him that is completely kind of
off-the-wall but also it's super fun in
a wonderful performance it adds so much
to the movie the performance and I feel
like this is a movie that could gather
sort of a cult sense because it is an
exploitation movie like it's hyper
violent and crazy but also like it is a
breakthrough in tech and I feel like
this is one of those films that could
have Teeter on the edge of like this
could be really terrible or surprisingly
awesome I came out thinking a
surprisingly awesome yank like they're
good performances in this movie pretty
much everything is inventive in this
movie yeah I walked away from this movie
feeling like this was everything I
wanted it to be plus a lot more even
though I had my concerns Mike my one
concern was that it was gonna get
annoying you know like I feel like they
thought about that and that's why I'm
they expanded it so much give us
different visual motifs or different you
know rules of the universe I think the
most impressive thing they did honestly
was the fact that they were able to give
this Henry guy a personality and you
live vicariously through him because he
had you you feel throughout the movie
it's more than just that was cool when
there's like an intense like suspenseful
scene it's [ __ ] feels that way cuz no
movie has translated the this is what
this could feel like like
moving like it like you are Henry like
it's a really cool film most likely
it'll be in my top five if not top ten
movies of 2016 so early in the year now
was it an experience that it's not
expecting one of the reasons I love
going to movies and it's so cool knowing
it was an IndieGoGo project that ya know
that the only real labor of love people
there were fans of this that wanted this
to be made and they donated so much
money to and it's awesome to see that it
was worth everyone's time and money it
was is a complete success and a bid on
this watching this journey since they
first released the indiegogo clip
mission accomplished
you have made one awesome experience of
a movie yeah everyone watch it oh you
like the music - I do like the music the
music's really good I can't tell you
what kind of music there is when the
movies actually released we'll probably
do a spoiler review yeah this is us
saying we want you guys yeah watch jeez
go check out please watch it they didn't
ask us to say it or none of that [ __ ]
you were just saying this because you
have to watch this movie you you may
have to work to get into it because I
understand like you know it may be a
little too intense for some folks but if
you can get into it it becomes just like
the most yeah fun ridiculous visceral
movie I'll say if you can get through
the opening credits you could probably
get through the whole movie if your
score meets of violence
my concern is like I want to take my
girlfriend to watch this movie but she
won't enjoy it and it's very you know
mainly because of how violent the movie
can get yeah and it's like as much as I
want to be like oh close your eyes here
sometimes it happens it's such a flash
memory yeah as a movie is a flash yeah
like it's cuz this movie is like a
stream of consciousness yeah a fever
dream and like it is because you're
strapped into this guy's point of view
the whole time like the movie does feel
frantic and when you're done with it
you're like what do we just go through
yeah you know and you and when you're
out of the theater you feel like your
look yeah the first POVs
it is like a oddly affecting experience
what I love about it it's an experience
it's like it's like when you go to
Universal but watch one of those like 3d
shows you know like people go here to
watch a show it's awesome likes awesome
this movie might not be perfect it has
some rough edges but I almost feel like
all that stuff adds to the charm because
it does not feel like a really cool
exploitation movie that brought some new
stuff and did it well yeah like it's a
bit mission accomplished listen listen
if you're new the channel subscribe
today become a reject it'll be worth
everyone's time especially your mom
she's a Jerry playlist on this channel
he's the coast cook creator of this
channel you can check him out on ding
cast those with him and this guy named
Aaron Aaron not a pedophile
want to make that clear why I just
talked with my representative over at
our multi-channel network fullscreen and
we have to get more followers on our
Facebook Instagram and Twitter so if you
guys can help us out there that that
would be great because we want you know
like brand deals so we can annoy you
guys with product placement well we can
bring you more stuff like we could make
you more and perhaps better stuff in the
future well I just like the free goods
know by a 1up box like that you call
them free goods as if they send you like
like necessities this had me canned
beets bottles of water toilet paper
never mind
this is this is what I deal with our
daily basis